hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to deep sleep a pixelated
style adventure point and click game
that a lot of people have been
suggesting that I play for a long time
now I don't know why I haven't but
there's now three in total games in the
series deep sleep deeper sleep and deep
asleep if you could even believe it when
you look into an abyss the abyss also
looks into you frederik niche and this
game has been around a while I don't
know if it's long or short all I know
that it is a point-and-click adventure
game I've just woken up
very good me I'm very Stu to my current
situation oh hello okay so what I'm
supposed to do in these games you
point-and-click until you find it oh
hello
do you find exactly what you need and
I'm assuming that this key is going to
go right in there yes okay no the world
was gonna start melting on me oh this is
cheerful I love the decor oh there's a
dead man in my bed did I just sleep with
that Skellington okay didn't know I
needed a piece of his arm but whatever
wait does that say something down there
I don't know if that's actually saying
something okay nevermind I guess I'm
done here those mountains in the
background what the hell just happened I
guess I fell asleep
maybe hello hello smells really bad from
there where am I
where am I in relation to any of this
[Music]
okay maybe delay babe
beware of the light bulb look what I get
it yeah I get it
hang up hang up the [ __ ] oh hello well I
didn't think that's what that has is was
do what the hell that's a lot of drawer
I've ever heard it's dead so am I so I
have to wake up and I gotta beware of
that light bulb
apparently all right that was fun let's
go on a different adventure often hello
what am I looking at there are big
cracks in this wall oh okay
wasn't that lovely oh good this is the
staircase from Mario 64 I'm sure this
note gets to you somehow at this point
you should know all this is not real
I hope the inner awakening wind wind
will and you have the full lucid control
over your dream sincerely yourself so
I'm gonna lose I'm in my own lucid dream
and I'm supposed to do what with that
knowledge won't budge and it's leaking
so do I need to do something about that
leak this is bone do anything what is
this a cube of the keyhole okay I keep
thinking I see some things but
oh it's dark in here it's two dogs oh
good okay I'm good I don't need to go
down there oh hello Gotham noises are
loud a piece of old cloth flashlight
with no battery oh hello
whoa okay I got a rock okay well you
have fun in the Sun I'm gonna go
elsewhere
geez now with is inferno inside good
good call breath good call me since I'm
parently I'm talking myself well ha BC
was the person who said that Elias s so
maybe I can use this rag mop this up or
maybe no that not right I thought that
might have been right maybe I'm wrong
maybe I'm very very Oh
Oh it did work by some gonna be the way
you do these adventure games you got to
make sure you touch everything to
everything else these at the end of the
day you need to make sure everything
gets along touch this thing dang anybody
any ghosty goos wanna mess with me huh I
could punch your and your ectoplasm oh
okay so the rag doesn't do anything on
the big cracks in the wall not that I
assumed it did that would be insane
oh maybe living water this I know it's
dead but give it a chance
hello sir you look sick maybe I'll dab
your forehead with a wet clothes do you
there anything under the bed is
everything under the blankets would you
write like me to reach my hand under the
blankets do you like me to fluff your
pillow you like me to fluff your crotch
no okay bye it's gotta be some I need
this cloth for
needs a lever Oh a bone I didn't even
know that was a thing ah there we go
kachunk got you okay
ouch the handle is hot as hell good
thing I got this wet cloth there we go
maybe this wasn't such a good idea now
that I'm remembering what was inside
here hello lovely ivz what let me look
at whoa whoa oh that's cool but at the
same time what the hell is going on I
just need to click away whoa what is
under here hello
oh it's code it's code code it's
kota-kun Lulu okay alright I need to
write this down
everybody bear with me a second not Deb
got double of lamb it okay look like
eight six one six any other secret
number Easter egg of sewers that's
really cool though that's actually oddly
really cool no goddamn it
okay so eight six one six okay six ones
and good thing I've done there okay so
can I have that back uh yeah you keep
the bone I'm just gonna go on my way and
find out where the hell this code Joe's
ding ding anybody wanna code
do I need to just walk through the halls
shouting eight six one six until someone
finds me and shuts me up for being
stupid I guess I got a key ding dong
okay I know where this key goes I know I
know I know I'm all over oh I'm with I'm
in it to win it
I got it hang on yeah yeah batteries
batteries got it okay got a flashlight
now now I can use this I can go on the
dark place not that I necessarily want
to go in the dark place that seems like
the opposite of what I should do cool
wake up I think I got that message
I really want to go in there ha okay oh
boy hey wait that looks familiar
oh hello a golden statue looks like
Stefano okay alright then how's he a
loony I'm following you
what's that way out I don't trust it man
I got to see what's on the other door
hello creepy horse I can't read that Tom
Cody is lost without his plushy tiger
okay
so bad but Cody okay I need to find a
plushy Tigers that we were saying about
a golden statue anything No ah piece of
coal lump of coal up your ass a little
Cody okay so I guess I go down this way
we got oh good it's normal where where
did I come out where am I okay okay well
uh hello I got a code eight six one six
okay
yeah that's disconcerting okay heavily
creepy okay okay oh it's dark flashlight
thank you oh this is good I can tell
this is all sorts of good heartbeat
heartbeats are always a sign of comfort
in the darkest of places
well my horror game instincts are
tingling where the boxes barrels towards
hey pickaxe that's good
okay okay who wanted to be where that
lightbulb I should've known the
lightbulbs right up there right okay
it's it's thumping its stump Aruna okay
I got a hook do I put the hook on my
hand and then I become foxy I don't know
jeez what's the point of that what was
the point of my Oh God you creepy
bastard okay goodbye
so what is that I don't know what these
things are
God those disturbing Kate never too dark
okay wait do I need to do anything with
thee
oh I'm trying to ah ha ha ha okay so I
do line I need to do something with this
horsey who oh wait maybe I knew I can
use the pickaxe on the broken wall oh is
that a service at this hotel is terrible
I don't much appreciate it okay that's
good sign alright I love it okay got it
hey look it's freedom question mark
then I make oh hello OSI ocean it's the
really creepy disturbing ocean
okay I got a net I'm gonna go catch some
fish going on here okay so that's the
hole in the wall there's some weird-ass
coasts the hell is going on
this may be a lucid dreaming if this is
what lucid dreaming is I don't want to
do it oh hello lady creepy painting
what's creepy about it's a beautiful
lady I spit everywhere
who cares hello up periscope
okay I'm like steering the lighthouses
we're gonna take off like a rocket ship
this is the beginning of this is the
beginning of Bioshock be where the
lighthouse may be whose be here where
the lighthouse got any something else
here
I'm else don't do this haha
okay I'm thinking that maybe I needed
something back the other way I got a net
so maybe then that can be used somewhere
else maybe wave so dark maybe I need to
go back down to the thing how am I gonna
find a [ __ ] for Cody there's got to be
something that I can do with this hey
there we go yes okay we got it we got it
we got it I got it I got it hello I get
it oh wait a minute
you were the call you were the call your
honor your honor a recording I get it I
have to wake up there we go I got a
shiny gem oh my god a diamond it's
minecraft holy how it looks somehow
familiar
something's like it looks like a unicorn
standing on the beach I don't know what
that's all about
- who's ringing me why do I have a blue
gem how am I supposed to do I'm not
touching I'm not going back there
hey come on stop being such a [ __ ]
alright so I'm assuming I need this blue
gem for something else maybe back at the
lighthouse I would be assuming there's
not many places for me to go here got it
I'm just having off - green eyes hello
Lee so what about this thing was able to
do that I just hold it down okay Oh
anything no okay so that did something
what do that did they are blocking the
way that's good okay I have to escape
hello this isn't happening so your dream
man I have to wake up creepy painting
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna breeze in your degree and then
just like that I woke up well alright
then if I didn't know there were two
more sequels I would just assume that
you were being a douche the nightmare
was over but my life had changed forever
has changed was it all just a dream
or where these creatures real I might
assume yes I have to know I just have to
know the truth I can't stop thinking
about it
I have to go back yes back to the deep
sleep that was really cool I really
enjoyed that it has some really creepy
moments for such a simple game that's
what it always surprises me about these
games that they can be so damn creepy
so either way this was deep sleep I'm
definitely gonna play part 2 and part 3
which just came out I don't know if
that's the last one or if there's gonna
be even a deep history sleep but this is
what I've got so far so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more horror games and out
of the stuff that I've done and as
always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
d'arnot unplugged in a bloody wild
[Music]